yes sir what's happening what's
happening I'm chilling brother it's good
to see you it's been a minute since I've
been like five years since I saw you
yeah what have you been up to uh working
hard working hard uh thank you smart
trying to maneuver get over obstacles
yeah I mean I saw you did Vlad like a
year ago and I saw I mean because listen
you have had one of the bigger records
in the last five years Envy me was a a
moment was it triple platinum uh it's
five times now five times Platinum my
goodness
that's fire that's gotta be a dope
plaque like did you get the five times
Platinum plaque yet no you gotta you
gotta buy that one yeah yeah I'm on it
I'm gonna get I stopped at three yeah
because I stopped that four every time
you get a new certification I need to
get a new plaque and it's like Jesus
Christ
um but yeah I mean I I know you kind of
went through it with uh with with the
label at the time because you were with
RCA
um now you're fully independent so
congrats to that I always congratulate
artists when they're independent because
I think it's the way to go finally free
type [__] what was the uphill battle for
you with
you know because from a Fan's
perspective a lot of people like we're
having a cowboy you know what I'm saying
so what what's been going on and what
was kind of some of the uh
you know things you had to go through
with getting out of that deal and and
trying to move on and and get this music
out that you're sitting on
um
well I would say one of the bigger
problems was like
the back end business
you know what I'm saying like getting
like different personalities to see eye
to eye things like that to actually get
the ball rolling that was very difficult
in my situation you know what I'm saying
in terms of just like agreeing on what
to put out agreeing on when to put it
out yeah yeah so from a fans perspective
it looks like uh Cal ain't working or he
ain't he don't care about us type and
then I kind of disappeared to them
I mean that's what I that's what I I was
like what happened to Cowboy my boy had
hit me and I was like oh because I
remember you did the Vlad interview that
went viral for other reasons yeah just a
lot of the BS behind closed doors just
slowed down the consistency and the flow
yeah because people don't understand
like when you're on a major label
it is very much a mutual relationship so
in their eyes
per your contract if you turn a body of
work in and we release it I owe you
money here's an advance for that album
right so in their eyes their their
perspective is
well we got to feel good about whatever
this is we got to agree on if if we feel
strong about all these records and then
that's when you know or you know you got
to catch a moment and force their hand
almost right you know what I'm saying so
there is always that gridlock on the
major label side yeah so that's that's
what it was for yeah for sure and I and
I figured it out I got up out of there
now we working was it easy to get your
well obviously it wasn't easy to get
your release but what like well tell me
about that process of getting released
off of it um it took a couple years yeah
um took a little money
uh took a strong um
support system
did you have to buy yourself out uh not
necessarily no okay but I had to uh
just let a lot of things go yeah
and if you get what I mean in terms of
like some of your music you recorded on
their dime yeah
so if like you record music on their
dime you might not ever hear that music
but do they still have the right Jesus
sorry do they still have the right to
release that music or is it just like
hey this is us you know what I'm saying
like you go do your thing yeah it's
really it's really like that I'm just
doing my own thing they ain't really
worried about the other music but I'm
sure they uh cause a hassle if I try to
like drop stuff on yeah yeah that makes
sense I've had friends of mine who've
like been on major labels and then
they'll get with like a really big
producer like let's just use an example
Timberland or somebody right right and
then they get off of the label but they
still got all these unreleased songs
with like
these giant producers and they're like
ah
do I have risk just throwing the [__]
out there to see what happens all right
you know I mean it can work both ways it
could work out or it could be like
yeah you get a cease and desist well
right now I'm working on like uh all
fresh music yeah you know the energy
that I'm in right now how I feel right
now so no the new song is dope I watch
the videos dope dope record you're
snapping on it for sure that was one of
the ones where I was just feeling myself
you know what I'm saying but
um that's the start of it Unchained just
explaining like what I really went
through for real yeah what for people
who don't know because I saw it I mean
you lost a lot of your personal friend I
think you lost like 12 friends in a year
no eight and two eight years eight
friends in two years yeah so that's
gotta be like three of them was family
members uh older cousin uh a younger
cousin
and uh a cousin around my age it's crazy
because we we hear that same story
coming from so many people from your
city right and it's like you know G
herbo has a song called PTSD and he
talks a lot about like uh the mental
strength you have to have to be from
where he's from where you're from you
know what I'm saying and and to deal
with so much loss and so much hurt like
do you ever feel like you had an
opportunity to really mourn
um
yeah behind closed doors when you were
by yourself you know what I'm saying but
um
you grow
I mean numb to it you know what I'm
saying you get used to it I wouldn't say
numb to it because you still care but no
but it's it used to yeah I mean it's
something you can get used to if you get
there's women out here who are getting
cheated on by the same guy for a decade
who I know and I'm like well you're just
used to it at this point like you don't
even care anymore like you like [__]
happens to you and unfortunately no
matter how traumatic it is like you're
kind of conditioned to deal with it you
know what I'm saying yeah I always say
it could be worse that's I mean
everything could always be worse so [__]
100 do you ever feel like uh you have
ever like
consider maybe hitting therapy talking
out some of your [__] like that I tried
that before oh you did yeah like uh
talking to somebody all the time
it work a little bit it's cool yeah but
um
I'd rather just do music for real like
that is your therapy yeah that's what it
is I love that
this album you're about to release is
your first album as an independent
artist right which is a big deal yeah
um this is a new space for you uh to be
who you are with already with a five
times platinum record and now you're
able to kind of move freely you're able
to kind of call the shots do what you
want to do how does it feel like it like
is is it something
there's got to be like a cool
Just Energy to that yeah yeah yeah I
feel free I don't know why I keep saying
that but that's what it feels like you
feel like a a weight is off my shoulder
you know I get to see certain things you
know what I'm saying I get to move how I
want to I mean it's just about a
positive energy all the way around you
know what I'm saying that's how I feel
you know so I'm excited for it I was
gonna say what would you say is your was
your biggest
um for people who think you just
disappeared what would you attribute
that to the reason of that is it the is
it the label thing or is it just
like what was what was what's the reason
why we haven't gotten a lot of music
from you in the last few years yeah it's
a label thing yeah it was a label thing
bro for sure is it hard to still stay
motivated if you feel like you're kind
of like
no
um
I'm still living yeah you know my two
feet still move you know what I'm saying
so I mean I'm grateful for that yeah and
I can work and I can grind I can do what
I want to do still so I love it man I
ain't tripping I always stay motivated
uh